Indy 100 reports an upset mom-to-be
recently asked for advice on Reddit
about a close family member using their
chosen baby name for their dog
she wrote they got the first and middle
name spelling it exactly how we were
planning and responders told her just
use the name anyway all right just put
that friend in the doghouse but do you I
didn't realize that it was before the
baby was born yeah which is why I always
tell my friends who are having babies
now tell the name never tell the name
one I don't care what you think I don't
care what you think about what I'm
naming my baby and two you're gonna
steal it all right show of hands who
thinks what this woman did by usurping
her friend's baby name for her dog
before the baby was born hands up if you
think it's not Kosher oh my gosh
yeah I totally agree